everyone on tomorrow and it is my
pleasure to be joined by Jake Decker
first of all from gamespot hey Jake
hello and then we have max pairs from CD
Projekt RED who obviously given your
background is that you work on cyberpunk
2077 you are level designer max how are
you thank you so much for joining us No
thank you guys for having me yeah
between the background and the the
aesthetic on the clothing I think yes I
think there's a slight clue as to what
you might be doing for set up Jake and I
have both played four hours each now of
cyberpunk and we're just gonna have a
bit of a chat about our experiences and
horse max your your level designer so I
guess some people who might not be super
familiar with what that means I mean
yeah on ik on a project as ambitious as
something like cyberpunk level design um
might not be easy to understand like
what part of that I you work out so what
is it that you actually do yeah man
that's a good point so to make clear to
anyone who's wondering level designers
we're the ones that create the spaces
where the missions will take place weird
like the virtual architects alongside
environment art we work on the open
world as well as alongside that also all
of the main missions as well that you
guys got to play through so yeah we work
open-world making spaces scripting some
of the events as well that's really the
role of it I'd like to say the
superheroes show us someone from the
team we'll find that out later but no we
you know one of the many amazing
talented people and disciplines that
makes game
I think obviously there's this this game
it exists the thing that I found and
Jacob sure can agree is like it has that
CD Projekt RED density of detail but
this game more than perhaps two witcher
series it's like crammed into a tighter
space like it's like i wrote about the
sense of like overwhelming overwhelming
kind of like sensory overload you get
immediately so what do you think was the
kind of major differences between how
you approach how the studio would
approach something like witcher where
they have these large open environments
and naturalism and that kind of soft
and an environment as a level designer
like night see where it's all like
crammed into basically what feels like a
shoebox yeah I mean the difference is
you mentioned is the density that's one
things that we really strive for and
working on this and making like city
feel like a living breathing place
because the fact that we want to feel
that you know comparing that to the
Witcher that you mentioned you've got a
lot more space a lot more different kind
of visuals and in terms of more
contrasting ones as the woodlands versus
cities elegant but here we do have
distinct districts but it is all in
place in one cities the challenge was to
make sure again it still had that very
lively vibe to that we're still able to
create a space where I felt lived in I
guess the challenge of that was making
sure that you felt that only by seeing
the people that you see Lin I see all
these different people having different
kind of activities during the day or
night also the different events that
you'll find throughout the city as well
so yeah but not all together has been a
challenge but also you know hopefully
you guys noticed when we played it how
it comes across as well it's definitely
something you know we are aiming to get
unlike a mechanical level when you're
creating these areas what goes into that
because with a game like cyberpunk you
have to account for I don't know
netrunner a solo all these different
types of play styles yeah may all people
just wielding pipes or lives like you
were doing no so like there's a lot of
stuff that goes into it and you know it
doesn't get this way just first try we
have to constantly iterate communicate
with the team but from the get-go we are
very aware that you know one of the key
pillars Rosamond making this game is
that a fluid class system that you have
that choice when you're making a sizable
to be able to actually play how you want
to play designer of character I'm sure
you all noticed the amount of options
whether it be clothing the weaponry to
your skills and abilities your cyber
where all of that is there so we don't
want to just make it cosmetic we want to
make it you know also impactful in the
gameplay so it takes a lot of time
planning and
just standing what's available to the
player but again through a lot of
iteration that's how we make it make it
better
yeah one of the things that I'm
interested in is kind of like how do you
talked about the density of each
environment and I think it's fair to say
like the density it's both it's the same
outside and inside it seems like you're
putting more effort into using the
environment to kind of direct the eyes
and move people through spaces a little
more how do you do that in an open world
where you can go anywhere and everyone
everything seems like a point of
interest and then how do you do that in
a smaller room where you just need
people to just funnel through yeah so
there are some big differences winters
like said open world versus more
contained areas but the environment team
like the RT interested in such a
phenomenal job I'm making it so
beautiful and that was part of the fun
making this game with all teams is
knowing that we want you to explore so
by having all these interesting spaces
that you can see it makes the play want
to go off and explore that so that was
something that we focused on and really
want to drive home so when people see
that we reward them whether it be you
know shots interesting characters that
you meet or maybe it's different events
going on so we kind of play off that so
I'm making sure that whatever catches
your eye there will be kind of a reward
in some sense or your exploration and we
want to keep that kind of going now when
it comes to that I love something more
contained like a mission space that's
where I guess the fun really happens in
the sense of you know we've been again
give those options off the option the
choice don't come from where to go like
the open world but it's also coming from
like how do I handle the situation
missions do I go gather Intel do I go
open this door through this hatch here's
I distract the enemies or do I go in
guns blazing so it's really about kind
of again given the options but
understanding how we do want the player
to mess around and the terminal
expiration wanted to play how they want
to play we don't want to discourage you
so that's some of the the fun of
designing they're sort of the freedom
forward to has there been like a certain
play style maybe that has been difficult
to
I guess implement into the levels or
make a natural sort of progression
through a level yeah that's a really
good question I think it's about making
sure that they all feel you know for
lack of a better word badass that you
feel cool when you play it so the net
Werner at first this was something we
constantly tried to work on to make sure
that it felt rewarding for hacking in
for distracting the enemies beginning as
we mentioned earlier took about
iteration it's well making sure that we
test and go over and all that but that
was the the first challenge is making
sure that each of these play styles
offer something cool to the player so
that I say was the biggest challenge and
then kind of balancing it out as we went
through oh yeah fingers crossed when
people play it they will have a great
time with it you know how does your kind
of approach vary from place to place
because nicely he has a bunch of
different districts right and like a
place like you know the witcher 3
environments this is kind of uniform
underlying kind of like naturalism to it
that you can almost use as a thread and
build off in different spaces or to a
large degree of it whereas this game
feels like you know nicely biased nature
is this cobbled together a mishmash of
cultures and identities and that kind of
stuff as a level designer what does that
mean is it tricky for you to be like
alright we've we can't just use the same
kind of like language visual language
across each of these things like how do
you approach creating distinct districts
and what was kind of like your technique
for that yeah I mean I think it all
comes from you know here is a project
read like story is king you guys have
played witcher and like how important
like each element of the story comes
into it and that's one of things we kept
thinking about and having you know the
great foundation is the tabletop game by
mike pond smith first like really was a
great you know foundation for us to
build upon and when you look at what you
guys played versus you know what we
showed last year which was Pacifica
there is a distinct difference because
that was left barren due to the fact
that you couldn't roll morning ran dry
and Wars and that yeah just destroying
desolated that place so we focus on
those elements so each each so district
that you'll explore does have its own
identity and that all comes from a story
from I was thinking about
which gangs occupied these area why do
they do that was the history of this
district we really go through and try to
think for the story of each kind of
element and that again just helps us
build and then when it comes to us as
level designers understanding that
really helps us then plan you know kind
of water texture can we use you know
something like just for example in that
of Pacifica where we said it's very
desolate and ruins but maybe that gives
us more options before using ruins
compared to what you guys saw in watts
and when playing off that so yeah story
always is that it's a big key for isn't
we just keep building from that can you
talk a bit about like the one thing that
really stuck out to me that I loved was
like the the kind of clashing of
cultures and language it says like loads
of sign yeah something starts off in
like English and then changes to like
kanji or hiragana or some other language
how did you approach taking those kind
of like different aesthetic themes and
and kind of like the tapestry of all the
cultures and mashing them together in a
way that also still feels cohesive if
you get I'm saying it's there's a lot of
thought that goes into two these days
obviously you want to give each culture
in some respects as well you know we
don't just force it in just to be like
checkboxes as you've seen there like so
it feels cohesive if something that we
think about because the fact that in
this storyline in this world it's not
representing ours but this version of
reality you know things got destroy them
ruined through different Wars climate
change and then more people had to come
together certain spaces you know if
anyone's favorite tabletop you'll know
the law kind of vacuum you know backing
it up and stuff and just studying that
and how eventually people had to come
together because the spaces were kind of
you know not inhabitable due to that so
it's about thinking about how people
would come together how the communities
would mix and gel and also take up their
kind of own space in a way as well as
communicating with one another so
there's a lot of thought again it all
comes from the great foundation of the
tabletop game helped us build that the
localization team the story team and
working so hard to make sure and it
feels that way so yeah everyone's done
I'm in job as far as I'm concerned
speaking at a tabletop game is there
yeah like when it comes to level design
is there anything very specific or maybe
not so specific that the level design
team has taken from the tabletop game
apart from maybe the different
approaches to areas yeah sort of a
question mate oh really good it's such a
high honor just thinking about it
I think well part of it is as well as
level design there's team know in the
environment as well one of the things
that we've taken for is making sure that
you know we talked about story but
selling that in the space as well you
know the levels aren't just there for
just the combat or the interaction with
other enemies or friendlies or anything
like that it's also there to help sell
the world so I guess when the challenges
is you know when you're playing that
tabletop game you might have imagine
imagine the world to be a certain way so
for us to it's tape and kind of you'll
bring it to life and try to think about
how is it that we do that to be
respectful and also give us the freedom
to represent it how we vision as well so
that's been one of the the other
challenges is bringing over people's
imaginations to life in a sense have you
guys ever done like a tabletop session
like smoke yeah and at the end the level
and then you guys are like whoa that's
pretty cool we should turn that into a
mission so not necessary a mission but
we've definitely done be the tabletop
playthroughs and just to I said really
helped us get to know the game and what
we're building on so yeah it's been
something we've done is if people
haven't played it I do recommend going
checking it out there's a lot more
there's a lot of depth to that compared
to other tabletop games so really offers
great deal so and then dude I think you
guys had my concert McDonough one point
if I'm not wrong here
so yeah you look experience that as well
and by the way he's got one of the best
voices I've ever heard how many of this
guy talk it's amazing
our video with him all the comments are
like damn that guy's voice I could
listen and talk all day
yeah it's crackin so ya know it's a
that's been you know one of the
challenges I said bringing the
environments to life but yeah we it's
been really fun sadly we didn't finish
our tabletop all the way through
we got through and you know I definitely
died a few times but we won't talk about
that well anybody that as as Ilona based
on what you can talk about is there any
particular part of the city or a level
that you really have taken a liking to
like and why what are the kind of things
that you personally as a level designer
that what speaks to you in in the world
I really want to mention like one
mission back on you know run through the
doors again it's taken too much but no I
think the thing that's really really has
like impressed me the most who touched
upon it then is where the star this was
the density you know the amount of like
feeling of being overwhelmed how crowded
the city is whether it's just walking
around with people versus you know going
around and something's happening around
you and how that changes depending on
day or nights as well so that is
something that you know super proud of
the team's just done an amazing job
everyone's working super hard so yeah
cracking job by April yeah I was gonna
add like as a starting point for nice EE
and obviously you have the table to how
much of it how much of it is like from
tabletop influence and how much of it is
from real-life influence like I was
walking through it and they I got the
same vibe being in there as my first
time being in Tokyo and like that
feeling of this is familiar but also I
feel like I'm under attack by everything
like they're like the thumping baseline
the chatter of people the kind of
distant sounds that kind of stuff what
were kind of your inspirations either
virtual or real that you called from
when bring it together nice II yeah I
mean there's definitely like you said
elements that were taken from with
reality you know the fact that it's
based in California obviously we looked
around that against its own cost the
environment around it you know Jacob you
played the nomad path the cilium same
kind of the desert vibes that we've got
palm trees to scatter around past the
city as well so we've taken it from you
know different elements was going around
making sure we have the
from got different teams base i got PR
teams somehow based over in china japan
and us they've been you know taking it
over some photo sending for us to like
study and learn from but the coolest
thing is obviously taken from them like
realities you mentioned and then
tweaking it in our kind of sad calm
vision I think that's the in the fun
part for most of the team one thing that
you know we've talked about is how there
are three different origin stories you
can essentially I think at the beginning
which are more or less three different
tutorials I guess you could say I mean I
don't want to just boil it down to
tutorials because there's a lot more to
it than that but like what when you're
trying to figure out the levels the
planning behind those different
scenarios like what are key
I don't know motifs or pillars or things
you're considering when it comes to each
of those origins yeah that's a really
good question I think for us it's about
making sure that they feel different
that you really do get a different sense
of your your life styles when you are
when you're playing this you know I'm
sure you guys have discussed the
difference that you guys saw when you
were playing through your different
playthroughs and really having having
that sense of feeling that they don't
feel that they're anyway related to or
know about the difference between the
stuff is so vast so again it feels more
related to you and your choice I think
that's one of the biggest things is
again just the vast difference between
how much of obviously the the the game
is designed the world is designed to be
like intricate and kind of this like a
maze of alleys and that kind of stuff
how much of it is designed to be learned
and kind of comfortable like a lot of
people that they find joy in
understanding of worlds and really
figuring out and knowing exactly where
everything is or as a nice city feels
like it's a place designed that you can
never really truly get a grasp on it
like how do you balance that out where
you want it to be a place that people
can get comfortable in or you don't want
it to lose that edge where it becomes
ordinary and predictable and kind of
like a familiar place to to to an
80-degree yeah thus couldn't give like a
percentage on how
she's marriages you know I think you
know again it Plaisance what we spoke
about with the density by layering
everything on top in that city you know
adds to that kind of maze like element
also shows how everything's stacked
typing on top of one another and I think
that's one of the cool science of it but
you will you know we talked about how
there's different things in terms of
landmarks as well as like different kind
of really visually appealing things that
can attract you around the city and
they'll definitely be you know once you
kind of figure out how they're all
connected it will help you but yeah it's
gonna definitely take some some time and
again that's part of reason why we've
want the player to explore we want you
all to go off and see how amazing like
city is yeah that's pretty much what I
did in my playthrough I would just get
out of the car and explore one of my
favorite things was the fact that I'd be
driving around and I'd see an alley and
I feel like huh I wonder what's over
there so I get out and check it out and
open up into this big market with like
ads blaring and and all these like mian
mian mian advertisement scattered around
and shops and whatnot and it's just like
holy [ __ ] this is all I just stumbled
across this by were just some
unsuspecting Ally and like seeing that
was this was exciting I had the same
thing where I went through an alley just
because I was following sounds and there
were there was a gang fight happening
and I was like I'm just gonna watch this
for a second for a few seconds and I was
watching and they were like kind of
shooting and eventually one of them
threw a grenade missed the person they
were going to and it like basically net
landed near me and I was like I am I am
this might sound like a stupid question
but like I'm genuinely interested like
how different is it designing a world
for a horse and a car I'm just thinking
of all the funny things of roached oh
yeah like is that gonna be a bit I'm
wondering where we have a car on our
roof meme like I'm sure I'm sure
someone's gonna find that you put that
out there I look forward to seeing that
me when it comes out but no like it is
different but also the similarities
Riley we understand
the speed is faster than on the foot
compared to roped versus Geralt or your
car versus V and it's definitely
something you know we've got some
experience on and I think them all I
think the biggest challenge is I don't
know how much you know how many vehicles
you guys messed around with but like you
can making sure they feel different as
well in terms the way a vehicle so that
changes how you move the speed you know
also like you know in Jacobs we ran
through some enemies in the car as well
like there was that kind of stuff so you
know thinking about how that comes in
affects it too so there are definitely
similarities but they said that the
focus has been more so making sure that
the vehicles feel right when you drive
them that's been a big focus for us
right and how much does the actual like
without giving it away how much does the
vehicle play into missions specifically
or is it more treat it as like a tool
for just getting around the city
obviously it's a futuristic car I
imagine it's got and you have in like
combat stuff in between actual
open-world but does that ever is there
like is there always like a hard line
between you're out in the world you
might get some combat in the car and now
you've gone into a mission
does it ever bleed back and forth yeah
definitely me I think you know that's
that's something we really focus on and
had some fun with you know when you guys
playing through when you rescue the
woman from that dingy apartment with
scabs occupy is you see that you know
eventually this bleeds out from just
when you're driving around normally and
they just randomly attack you so it is
part of that we don't want to just be
you know we just use it to drive from
point A to point B we want to be full of
you whether it is just driving and doing
you know handbrake turns throughout the
city you're running and attacking
enemies with your vehicles or going out
and having gunfights with it so there's
a lot of elements that play into that so
yeah we make sure that we balance it out
through it so yeah anyone on watching
this video can check out plenty more
cyberpunk 27 cent on the site and on
YouTube we've got videos coming and
we're available now and coming over the
next few days so please do check it out
if you have any questions for us let us
know because we will be doing a Q&A
video of
our experience with the game so if you
got any of those burning questions drop
them in the comments below there's a
preview on the site as well and yeah
we've got a lot of cyberpunk stuff on
the way but yeah in the meantime you can
find us on Twitter I'm at 2 more H Jake
I met Jacob Dec max you wanna plug your
IMAX Pass so like the proof thank you so
much all right
you